you go up and you punch Dwayne The Rock
Johnson in the face he's stronger than
you
yeah yeah does anyone feel bad for you
when you get hit back nope why do why do
women get an excuse if a
if it's hit back nobody feels bad for
him why is it that if a weaker woman
hits a stronger man and she gets hit it
I can't say it again so if a woman hits
a man no your argument was strength so
you said you said women women are not as
strong as men but I'm saying so if he
goes up to Dwayne The Rock Johnson Big
Jack dude and hits Dwayne first yeah
nobody is going to feel bad for him when
he gets knocked the [__] out because you
shouldn't have messed with him why do
women feel like it's acceptable
oh wake up at night because I'm stupid
yeah